[Aplausos]
creo que es el perfecto maridaje es
tomar ese vino con ese corte con la
persona que amas o con las personas que
vas a disfrutar que voy a pensar con un
viejo cuento que narra que un hombre
caminaba por la playa cuando encontrado
un niño que se agachaba cada momento
recoge un poco de arena y lo lanzaba al
mar una y otra vez cuando se dio cuenta
que en realidad recogía las frágiles
estrellas de mar una a una las arrojaba
de nuevo
intrigado le preguntó por qué estaba
haciendo eso y le respondió estoy
devolviendo a estas estrellas de mar al
agua como ves la marea es baja y pueden
morir deshidratadas
el hombre le dijo entiendo pero debe de
haber millones de estrellas de mar sobre
la playa y nunca podrás devolverlas
todas son demasiadas y esto sucede en
cientos de playas a lo largo de la costa
lo que estás haciendo no tiene sentido
el niño sonrió se inclinó como una
estrella de mar y mientras la lanzaba de
vuelta al mar le respondió para esta
sitú y para esta otra también el hombre
sonrió se inclinó como una estrella de
mar mientras decía y para ésta también
gracias a que alguien tuvo una gran idea
y además la realizado es porque muchas
estrellas y muchas personas han tenido
la oportunidad de transformar su
historia
nació en un pequeño poblado llamado
patla
una comunidad indígena en que el 100%
habla totonaco mi lengua nativa es
totonaco y aprendí a hablar español
hasta los 7 años muy poco por lo que se
me dificultó mucho mucho al llegar a la
ciudad de mexico quede prácticamente
huérfano a los 2 años mi padre era
alcohólico me descuido y pues no tenía
para donde mirar me cuidaban todas las
familias del pueblo entre ellas mi
madrina de bautizo ya vieja pues no me
podía dar los beneficios que tenía para
un ser humano dormí a veces con muchas
personas
otras veces o muchas de ellas dormía en
la calle sobre todo en los parques
afortunadamente en un pueblo había mucha
fruta había muchos lados de donde poder
comida y este sobrevivir así
durante seis años recuerdo que me
cambiaba o cambiaba de ropa me daba cada
seis meses
si alguien me ofrecía o me regalaba una
prenda no tenía ni siquiera sandalias y
zapatos caminaba descalzo
y bueno durante seis años a los seis
años tuve mi primera experiencia en que
casi pierde la vida en un pueblo no hay
luz eléctrica
es difícil obtenerla y lo que usábamos
era un candil un candil que es como
buenos usa petróleo es un poquito más
denso y sentí que alguien me empujó yo
por la cocina me resbalé y el candil
voló y empapó mi playera que pues
obviamente encendió todo y es donde casi
pierdo la vida mi padre dejó un poco el
alcohol por lo que había sucedido me
llevaba en brazos a un pueblo lejano a
unos 8 kilómetros caminando solo para
que me hicieran curaciones todo mi
estómago está lleno de cicatrices porque
porque en esa clínica solo te hacían
curaciones literal y te inyectaban tengo
como mil inyecciones solo para el dolor
con vendas bueno
tres meses después mi padre volvía a lo
mismo había perdido ya dos esposas así
que
no lo justifico pero así pasó
lo quiero muchísimo lo quise muchísimo
y lo que buscaba del niño pues era
encontrar algo de trabajo para que yo
pudiera tener comida sobre todo vestido
veía los demás niños que tenían ropa
zapatos calzado y este se me dio la
oportunidad cuando uno de mis compañeros
trabajaba en la ciudad de mexico y yo
anhelaba con ella de la ciudad de méxico
porque era la capital en donde toda la
tecnología todo lo bueno está y pues
bueno yo le pedí como cierto permiso a
mi amigo de poder mismo y con él y él
accedió porque porque su patrón estaba
completamente borracho se fue
exclusívamente una fiesta al pueblo me
subo al coche a escondidas ya medio
camino se enteran de que pues oye qué
hace este niño aquí porque está cal no
se preocupa nadie por él
le preguntan a mi amigo me dice no
efectivamente el dije que no que no se
preocuparía a nadie por mí que me diera
la oportunidad y accedió
la prueba que me da esta persona fue de
vender dulces
lacalle en los parques como no tenía el
conocimiento que también este amigo
también recibía maltrato infantil
en una de las me daba comida por
supuesto me daba vestido a veces me
dejaba
me dejaba dormir en la azotea de su casa
imagínense el frío a veces en la noche
en cartones y con un poco de cobijas
pero pues vivía más o menos pero
definitivamente quería regresar a mi
pueblo era libre lo poco que tenía era
feliz y pues con lo poco que tenía me
agradaba vivir en el pueblo puede ir a
nadar pudiera cortar mangos podría
ayudarle a la familia si quería
definitivamente regresar y no quedarme
con este señor que me está explotando y
ya lo sabía de niño porque porque yo
buscaba el bienestar para mí y no no lo
estaba ganando no me pagaba
en uno de estos días se me dio la
oportunidad cuando una persona que me
caía muy bien con el poco español que
hablaba
una señora que quería mucho
el regalón dulce mi patrón me vio y se
mojó
golpe en la cara yo niño la cosita
llorando
con rabia y este dolor sobre todo en el
pecho no solo por el golpe de la cara de
no poder hacer nada en ese momento
agarra el dinero que me dio y me mandó
por más dulces para que completamos el
stock que pues ya había gastado por lo
que había regalado cuando fue solo un
dulce es bueno agarra el dinero
y me dirigí hacia la central del norte
para irme a mi pueblo quería regresar a
mi pueblo
llegando a la central del norte pues me
encuentro con muchos problemas primero
menor de edad no pues no me pueden
vender un boleto segundo traía 70 pesos
el boleto costaba 120
tercero no hablaba bien español y no
conocía el cuarto es que no conocía el
lugar exacto de dónde venía
sólo dije villa juárez en el país
cuántos villa juárez hay muchísimos no
hasta ahora lo entiendo
en eso me llaman los cajeros y me dicen
que vamos a trabajar te vamos a ayudar y
te vamos a mandar unos trabajadores
sociales para que te apoyen y que
investiguen dónde vives yo con espanto
dije no sé a dónde me van a llevar no yo
me quiero a mi pueblo no si yo estaba en
ella y corrí porque pensé que me iban a
robar o hacer algo
con el poco dinero que tenía fui tenía
mucha hambre y ya era muy tarde compré
una torta un refresco afortunadamente en
ese tiempo eran muy baratas las tortas
estaba incómoda 18 pesos y creo que el
arco que estaba en 7 pesos y perfecto y
era una torta gigante de esas que guarde
la mitad para la noche porque porque si
hacía falta entonces pues decidí era mi
plan regresarme a mi pueblo porque pues
definitivamente si no puede hacer nada
en la ciudad tenía que dirigirme a donde
por lo menos sabía cómo sobrevivir y
cómo salir un poquito adelante viva los
dormir en los parques también ahí dormía
en las calles íbamos a por unos
compañeros que conocía en la calle
y vamos a los mercados ayudamos a las
señoras que traían sus mandados a cargar
las nuevas a su coche o donde iban nos
regalaban dos pesos un peso y así 45
horas de plante hacías de una lanita
40-50 pesos que serán muy buenos en ese
tiempo pero mi plan era regresar nos
bañamos en una en una pequeña fuente que
estaba ahí y obviamente también ya
compré un poquito de ropa y a la semana
regresé ya con el fin dije bueno lo que
pasa
si me roban donde secuestran o me hacen
algo que pase pero ya quiero regresar a
mi pueblo ya ver qué sigue
regresé y me dijeron lo mismo menor de
edad se llama él pensaba el dinero no
sabían de dónde venía y bueno dije pues
vamos con los trabajadores sociales y
este y pues que ellos deciden a ver qué
rumbo toma mi vida
y qué bueno que fui con ellos
me comentaron que a los dos meses iban a
regresar me dejaron en un albergue
temporal en donde pues obviamente apoyan
con comida dormir todo lo que se
necesita y este dijeron que muy bien
apoyar investigando de dónde dónde venía
quién me cuidaba y quién se preocupaba
yo no les dije nada de lo que estaba
pasando simplemente les dije a ver a ver
qué investigando de dónde de dónde vengo
y todo por el miedo no porque yo quería
aún sentía temor cuando estaba en el
albergue
entonces este a los dos meses regresan y
me dicen tenemos dos situaciones una es
mala porque porque tu papá ya
encontramos donde vives tu papá ni
siquiera se había dado cuenta de que te
has ido y sigue en el alcohol hablamos
con él estaba alcoholizado y no sé si no
se entendió y no tienes ninguna otra
familiar
pero tenemos una muy buena
la mejor es que te vamos a a
en dónde vas a poder desarrollarse como
ser humano
vas a tener educación vas a tener muchos
amigos y me dicen tenemos dos nombres el
mexicanito y el internado infantil
guadalupano
obviamente opté por el internado
guadalupano en el que pues bueno es por
creencia porque una persona mi madrina
de bautizo era la que me cuidaba
pues dije pues ese y agárrense internado
y fue cuando se abrieron las puertas
llegando al internado se me abre un
mundo de yo creo que de humanidad por
primera vez en la historia de mi vida
había probado tres alimentos al día
desayuno comida y cena
me veo bañado con agua caliente
limpia me dieron ropa me dieron mi
propia camita y mi propio locker
fabuloso
pero más que eso lo más importante era
que había un grupo de personas que
cuidaban de mí desde que me levantaba el
hermano los hermanos lasallistas después
llegaban los maestros con el poco
españoles recibía bullying todos mis
compañeros todo era el totonaca después
siguió siguió reduciéndose aún ahora ya
con orgullo lo digo mis amigos de la
universidad me dicen todo pero muchos de
ellos no saben porque algunos dicen es
que porque te gusta el grupo no sé grupo
de rock botón o por el perrito totón hay
toda una historia en el internado pues
habíamos muchas personas casi 200 niños
de diferentes edades de diferentes
situaciones económicas o de problemas
de los que yo traía de situaciones de
calle este pues yo creo que pero es a
veces que los míos
tener una maestra que me ayuda a
regularizar me y aprender un poquito más
el idioma español y pues el objetivo
principal del internado era pues darme
educación y que yo fuera una persona no
un ser humano
terminé exitosamente la primaria
sexto año casi los primeros años fueron
muy difíciles sacaba 678 máximo en
matemática en matemáticas era muy bueno
soy muy buena esté en español terrible
y terminé sexto de primaria con un
excelente promedio y los hermanos me
dieron la oportunidad de elegir
una escuela privada
fabuloso fiel la escuela privada por
primera vez ya conocí a niñas
kaká este por primera vez ya convive ya
con más gente y vamos a fiestas nos
llevaban a diferentes lugares en este
internado y ahora ya había formado una
familia en el internado
pero todavía seguía esa espinita de
querer tener una familia de querer
disfrutar de querer regresar a la raíz a
lo que me hacía feliz no era que fuera
yo infeliz en el internado ya tenía todo
ya sabía matemáticas dije no ahora sí
lago donde sea me voy atrás estado metro
ya tengo educación no siempre había esa
espinita de querer trabajar y este y
querer solventar mis propias necesidades
y acabé el primero de secundaria muy
bien
pues bueno deje un poco el internado me
fit como tuvo un rebelde pero me fue muy
mal
trabajé era albañil un rato trabajé de
de carpintero ayudante de carpintero
también ayudante albañil y puesto tal
mejor muy mal y arrepentido como cual
hijo pródigo hable al internado y le
dije hermano me está yendo muy mal y
necesito que me apoyen
échame la mano y le voy a echar muchas
ganas
y si me dijo regresa te estábamos
esperando
regrese y con todas las ganas que traía
y todo ese arrepentimiento que había
acumulado después de ese año perdido y
de trabajar pues dije la educación es lo
que nos hace falta termine la secundaria
con excelentes calificaciones
y el internado me dio una otra beca para
otra prepa privada
excelente la ciudad méxico terminando la
prepa igual con excelentes
calificaciones ya sabiendo un poco de
español aprendiendo un poco ya de
inglesa
me fui a becaron en una ciudad cercana
de león guanajuato en donde estudié la
licenciatura en administración de
empresas turísticas
y bueno todo esto
que les platicó
es gracias a que a esta comunidad del
internado a los amigos del internado
a los maestros a los hermanos sin ellos
yo no sé qué sería de mi vida no sólo
hablo por mí había muchas personas que
eran más de más edad que salieron siendo
maestros carpinteros que no tuvieron la
posibilidad de seguir estudiando pero
que sin embargo en interna bless les
brindó eso
pues es gracias a ellos que forme una
familia es gracias a todas estas
personas que hoy cuenta con una familia
y bueno terminando la universidad dije
pues es tiempo de volar de vida consumen
gracia un amigo
y bueno dije pues terminamos de la
universidad puedo empezar mínimo como
gerente o capital
llegando aquí meses hoy y sabes inglés
sabes esto que sabes ya tienes la
licenciatura pero pues que más no sabía
distintivo h yo me dedico a la hotelería
gastronomía restaurantes no sabía de
cristal no sabía inglés no sabía ni
siquiera que era una copa riddle que
como trapear la tenía la base la
educación la contabilidad de todo pero
pues más allá no entonces pero poco a
poco se dieron las cosas este mes
certifique como sommelier
y después me fui con otros estándares
como aprende inglés hablo inglés fluido
un poco de francés también y bueno poco
a poco ya hemos viajado en otros países
a aprender del tema de los vinos y esto
gracias a todas las personas que
hicieron en mí un ser humano y quiero
finalizar con las palabras que escribí
que no son fáciles de mencionarlas
tengo muchas cosas todavía por
transformar y construir y tengo
compromiso de no defraudar a quienes han
confiado en mí quiero que mi vida sea un
homenaje al internado ya todos quienes
me transformaron en alguien mejor en un
ser humano tengo convicción y el interés
de hacer algo por quienes más lo
necesitan quiero decirles que vale la
pena apostar por las estrellas que salen
del mar que tiene sentido vale la pena
ayudar a quienes ayudan para que nuestro
país y nuestra sociedad sean mejores tal
vez no aprendan nada hoy de mí no soy
alguien erudito soy una persona que
gracias a muchas personas presentes y no
presentes es que soy alguien muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]